this is a very interesting place here at
hols Mark and if you really pay
attention there's a lot going on on an
invisible scale you see Francisco
finding them in in every little Fountain
and these little algae have a skeleton
Built of Glass or silicon dioxide which
is extremely
beautiful
[Music]
hello my name is franciska gal I'm here
at Hol Mark 25 to participate in the
first Arts and Science Forum of Berlin
science week I'm a researcher uh
studying underwater noise pollution in
underwater
environments
I saw you scratching some things on the
water and I was like what is she doing
and then you were talking that you
searching researching on diems what's
going on like what do you see in the
water so we are scouting for some uh
very special micro algae that has some
internal shells made of glass made of
pure glass with specific photonic
properties so let's check it out this is
a very interesting place here at hols
Mark and if you really pay attention
there's a lot going on on an invisible
scale we might encounter a lot of
different species of diatoms they
live normally in this Parts they also
live in the mud the diatoms live in
every body of water salt water fresh
water and they are responsible for 40%
of the oxygen so they are very important
for the
ecosystem the performance we will also
set up a small wet lab in the beginning
where people can see see the diatoms on
on the microscope then we will do the
performance later where we upscale these
these diatoms to the ice sculptures and
there will be interaction of lasers of
sound and of ice sculpting in real
time Fran cisa's project I think is
extremely exciting because she is
looking at one specific type of algae
which is diatoms in German it is kisel
Al
which is almost everywhere you see
Francisco finding them in in every
little Fountain and these little Aly
have a skeleton Built of Glass or
silicon dioxide which is extremely
beautiful these skeletons have nanopores
which are ordered and this order and
disorder transition is what we are
interested
in I'm working at The palud Institute
for solid state Electronics we have one
combined event here at Holz Mark which
is a panel discussion about phase
Transitions and then we will have
exhibitions in Zin around these panel
discussions which show different works
on phase transitions from scientific
institutions and then we end the evening
transiting into this um project by
francisa some might know we're usually
working in very clean environments our
Laboratories are clean rooms with very
specific machines and we're opening up
to go here at Holz Mar because I think
it is essential to combine these
different worldviews to see what is done
in a very clean atmosphere in a very
artificial system and bring that into
society bring that into the open in my
opinion Arts and Science have many
touching points have many methodologies
that are very similar uh with outputs
very different and this I I believe this
is the beauty of combining them is that
you can reach a higher uh
audience I think I have to check that
out what do I think when I think about
hzm it's about this village where you
can really where you have where you can
open your mind where it's so much
freedom and this is basically especially
in Berlin a very unique place I would
say and I think it's the best place to
host the art in science fair and we in
science week because it's all about
opening each other's mind and um the
freedom of curiosity and the freedom of
Art and Science so it makes so much
sense we do this this year for the first
time here in this wonderful
venue
[Music]
[Laughter]
cool